uh this is absolutely fascinating and
infuriating and i want to be super
careful here to ensure that i'm not
violating any guidelines on any of our
platforms
we finally found one example
of what the right has been calling dead
people voting and of course
it wasn't a dead person it was a live
person doing something
illegal a pro-trump pennsylvania man
has been charged with voter fraud for
casting a ballot for donald trump
under his dead mother's name i'm going
to get into the details in a moment but
remember
the voter fraud trumpist crowd for seven
weeks now has been saying
hundreds of thousands of dead people
voted for joe biden in the 2020 election
in some cases they say tens of thousands
when this was investigated it turned out
that it happened
essentially not at all most of the
people listed as dead
in i believe it was in michigan were
just alive
i mean that that that's really they were
people who did vote
but they're alive they're not dead
others were
registered they died since registering
and they didn't vote so in other words
they showed up as registered because
they were but they died and didn't vote
because dead people can't vote
uh some others were name confusion a
junior
voting and then it being counted uh as
their dad's vote
senior um who has passed away but it was
still only one vote counted it wasn't it
being counted twice for one person it's
a clerical error
and of course the implication always was
that this was part of a scam to help joe
biden steal the election
another claim they didn't have any
evidence for aside from the fact that
it's really a bad strategy to steal an
election it's so much work for
one vote in this way but we finally
found
out that somebody did do this and it is
a 70 year old man named bruce bartman in
pennsylvania
who registered his dead mother and his
dead mother-in-law to vote
using the online registration portal
registered them both as republicans
requested absentee ballots in their
names and returned one of the absentee
ballots for his deceased mother
voting for trump he's confessed he made
a statement to the da's office
saying he cast a vote for his in the
name of his dead mother
for donald trump and there are many
takeaways here
first of all the claim from the trump is
that this is widespread
is a fantasy pennsylvania received
hundreds of
tips about supposed dead voters they
followed up on all of them
and they found one and it the guy voted
for trump okay
number two the story from the right is
always that
it's democrats doing the voter fraud and
yet every time it's investigated every
election
it's a handful of republicans doing it
there was a similar story back in
2016 maybe 2018 maybe both
there were scary generalizations about
voter fraud but when we found the few
instances of people doing it earnestly
uh it was republicans we found instances
of republicans
testing the system trying to vote twice
and they got caught
and once again here 70-year-old
republican
caught submitting a ballot for trump in
the name of his dead mother
one other republican in pennsylvania was
also charged
for casting a ballot in person went home
put on sunglasses went back to the
polling place and claimed to be his own
son to vote a second time
he's also been caught and charged so
again
no evidence of materially relevant voter
fraud
but these two guys accused of individual
fraud which of course would not have
affected the pennsylvania results either
way
joe biden won by 71 000 votes
but the two instances were people voting
for trump anyway
so it only took seven weeks but we
finally found
one supposed dead voter and it was a
trump vote anyway
so do not fall for this stuff my friends
it really will rot your brain we have
real problems to deal with in this
country
we have real election problems and they
include suppression
closing of polling places
disenfranchisement of different kinds we
have a long list
quote dead people voting not a problem
one guy did it he got caught in
pennsylvania
remember that on january 1 we are
blowing out memberships before joe biden
comes into office and says david
70 membership discounts are no longer
allowed
that's a joke by the way but we really
are doing a one-day membership special
january 1st 2021 if you would like to be
notified
about it this is very simple you go to
davidpakman.com
upper right of the website you type in
your email address puts you on our
newsletter
january 1st you'll get an email telling
you how to sign up
taking advantage of this great
membership special let me know what you
think
about the voter fraud story from
pennsylvania
you can find me on twitter at dpakman if
you are
anything like me you probably aren't
thrilled with the idea of going into
a doctor's office right now and
thankfully there is a
practical and affordable way to take
control of your health
and get personalized care from the
comfort of your home
it's a service called steady md they're
one of our sponsors
you take a quiz you get matched with a
licensed primary care physician
who understands your health needs you
have a one hour
video call with your new doctor you
establish a meaningful relationship with
them and after that
your doctor is available to you anytime
by text phone or video chat this is not
a random doctor on call
each doctor at steady md has a limited
number of patients so they actually have
time
to listen to you you get the personal
attention that you deserve
they can do almost everything an
in-person doctor
can do perform medical evaluations talk
to you about health concerns
send prescriptions to your home or local
pharmacy
and anything they can't do online
they'll quickly set you up with
an in-person provider to do things like
blood tests as an example
you don't need insurance it's only 99
bucks a month with
no other fees or copays there are so
many
practical advantages to using steady md
for primary care
and it's also so much more affordable
go to steadymd.com pacman to take the
free quiz see which doctor is right for
you i took their quiz they matched me
with a doctor
who specializes in my particular health
needs and situation the doctor they gave
me
is a really perfect fit for me and my
medical needs there's no risk no
commitment to get started
just click the link right underneath
this video